là il ya un truc important croyez-vous à
messieurs au psg et j'ai des infos
puisque hier qu'est ce qui s'est passé
hier
hier j'ai appelé nasser le président
nasser de siemens direct ah mais oui
et regardez ça a été repris partout
partout partout partout partout partout
partout partout on se tenir ça va mon
acer et toi dis moi mon acer est ce que
c'est vrai que messi va venir au psg
parce que tu m'as agité là tu peux pas
parler de ça en tout cas
mais voilà en tout cas ce que fait un
gros bisou et si messi bien au psg je
prend 8 abonnement pour des
téléspectateurs et moi d'accord une
centaine n'inquiète pas nasser je
t'embrasse fort et tu sais que tu sais
que je t'aime fort et que je suis avec
toi toujours je t'embrasse à barcelone
je t'embrasse allumons à serge temps
mois de fort alors que vous avez des
infos parce qu'après voilà alors
l'intervention déjà de nasser hier dans
l'émission était repris partout dans le
monde
regardez ça c'est un truc de ouf au
royaume uni ils ont parlé de nous non
merci ou regarder un gars au royaume-uni
d'abord oui mais bonne témoin que voilà
deux cas les filles does not be nice
mais si tu veux dire si markov note gina
il va patiner avec we see donc
et oui y lisent quanzhou zoopôle donc
cyril hanouna oui cyril hanouna ils ont
pas et nous n'y sont pas nés au portugal
messi n'a oppose sauf à l'art disent au
fond ça veut dire 'est-ce que tu prends
du poisson pour dîner mais si voilà ils
en ont parlé au portugal ils ont parlé
en italie après la fille noriega l'
option mais si ça veut dire que dans sa
voiture il va mettre une option spéciale
voilà ils l'ont dit ou en italie oui ou
pas en grèce
regardez c'est le seul truc de fou au
brésil c'est pas des mythos à la
houillère hanouna tout ça en brésilien
touche pas
traduire cyril hanouna nigou parra au
mandat pargneaux c'est à dire que j'aime
pas les mandarines en egypte à l'origine
on egypte bien sûr on est tous été
repris par tous et bien sûr ça a été
repris
même en france même à faire même en
france dans le parisien voilà à regarder
alors est ce que c'est possible mais si
au psg on a des infos je voudrais dire
un truc déjà c'est que nasser hier comme
je suis un petit peu dur de la feuille
jamais entendu on a tout il a dit je
t'ai à barcelone non en fait nasser est
à londres
messi et il a dit messi est à barcelone
entendu mes sites à barcelone il n'est
pas paris pour l'instant c'est pas dans
les tuyaux
j'ai quelques petites infos et guillaume
aussi dit oh non c'est fou parce que
déjà en 30 secondes vous avez réussi à
avoir une info que tous les journalistes
sportifs galère à avoir depuis des mois
parce que ça fait des mois qu'on parle
un peu l'artois demeure une bonne
personne et ça il le sait moi je pense
que oui messi va aller au psg parce que
de savoir si mais si vos péchés que va
pas appeler le président de marseille
il faut certes le psg ils ont toujours
fait des démentis quand les rumeurs
étaient fausses dans le fait qu ils ne
démentent pas d'information je pense que
c'est vrai nom mais l'a pas démentie l'a
pas compris il est au téléphone y avait
des gens devant lui a dit je peux qu il
a dû voir à douna il a dit qu'est ce
qu'il veut sinon mais là il a dit je
peux pas en parler donc pour moi ça veut
dire que c'est vrai oui messi sera au
psg l'année prochaine et en tout cas
c'est c'est très fort d'avoir eu cette
information est la vraie question qui se
pose maintenant c est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir garder nma et mbacké et mais
sinon je vais vous dire où il va aller
il va aller à manchester city
pourquoi parce que sa femme antonella
roccuzzo depuis cet automne elle est en
train de chercher des appartements dans
la banlieue chic et oui elle cherche des
appartements pour toute la famille mais
si donc voilà pourquoi l'humain et oui
de théière ou à londres à londres walter
et ana c'est parce que maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il n'est pas en train
justement de régler tous ces petits
contrats là ce que paris joue à la
délation
6 quels rapports en tout cas lui mais
c'est pas là c'est toi la london je te
résume en fait qu'ils regagnaient elle
encore dire je te mets si ils valent à
manchester city mais c'est nasser le
président du psg qui va lui chercher son
apparat
accueil a débattu crois que ce serait
pas de place à laser et ce qui se trame
la barre des contrats qui sont en train
de se faire en tout cas sa femme elle
cherche un appartement depuis cet
automne une bonne on vous donnait
suspens de la conseil continuez
d'écouter des mutuelles sur une radio
moi je pense sincèrement je le dis que
messi va venir au paris saint germain
neymar va absolument jouer avec lui
barcelone n'a pas assez d'argent pour
faire venir neymar et messier a envie de
partir il l'a toujours dit et hier c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas eu de démenti
voilà donc c'est vrai que vous avez
déroulera non par contre j'ai moins de
moi j'ai compris que il avait très bien
compris ce que vous lui disiez au
téléphone donc quand il est tout à leur
ouïe vous et croyez le suis sûre et
certaine
et je pense que si je pense que c'est
une bonne option surtout que mba paix on
ne sait pas encore s'il va rester et on
va falloir combler peut-être un départ
des maps et donc si elle bat p 120 mais
que messi arrive avec neymar je pense
que pour le public parisien
c'est quand même une très très bonne
chose et puis voir messi avec le maillot
du psg satine et moi je venais on est en
période de crise
du coup mais les clubs de foot ils ont
plus assez d'argent les stades sont
vides et c est ce qu ils ont de quoi ils
vont trouver
est ce qu'avec la vente des maillots
déjà tu te tuer
vous avez eu un retour de nasser après
cette intervention à jouer dit il m'a
dit mon syrie syrine je suis à londres
j'ai pas derrière les autres et y aller
je suis à londres je ne suis pas abba
cela nous fait là tu voir le post sur
les faits mais voilà tout simplement